>>> NEW NEVER-BEFORE-HEARD
INTERVIEWS WITH FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHERE HE SEEMS TO SUGGEST
AND THEN BACKTRACK THAT HE
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> DID YOU LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH ANYTHING IN PARTICULAR?
ARE THERE ANY MEMENTO DOCUMENTS
YOU TOOK WITH YOU, ANYTHING OF
NOTE?
>> NOTHING OF GREAT URGENCY.
I HAVE GREAT THINGS, THE
LETTERS, THE KIM JONG-UN
LETTERS.
>> YOU WERE ABLE TO TAKE THOSE
WITH YOU?
>> I THINK THAT'S IN THE
ARCHIVES, BUT MOST OF IT IS IN
THE ARCHIVES, BUT THE KIM
JONG-UN LETTERS.
I HAVE INCREDIBLE LETTERS WITH
OTHER LEADERS.
>> THAT WAS MAGGIE HABERMAN
INTERVIEWING TRUMP, AUTHOR OF
"CONFIDENCE MAN, THE MAKING OF
DONALD TRUMP AND THE BREAKING OF
AMERICA."
CNN POLITICAL ANALYST MAGGIE
HABERMAN AND SENIOR
CORRESPONDENT AT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" WITH US ON THIS.
THAT IS SO INTERESTING BECAUSE
HE KIND OF ANSWERS IT BOTH WAYS,
AND INCREDIBLY EVASIVE ANSWER.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THIS.
>> EXACTLY WHAT YOU JUST SAID,
BRIANNA.
IT WAS A VERY VAGUE STATEMENT.
I ANSWERED THE QUESTION ON A
LARK, KNOWING HOW HE LIKED ITEMS
LIKE THOSE KIM JONG-UN LETTERS.
INITIALLY NO, NO, NO, THEN HE
WANTED TO BRAG SOMETHING.
WHEN HE REGISTERED MY SURPRISE,
HE TOOK IT BACK.
IT WAS A CLASSIC MOMENT IN
INTERVIEWING HIM.
WE OBVIOUSLY LEARNED MUCH
LATER -- WE DIDN'T KNOW IT FROM
THAT INTERVIEW -- LEARNED
SEVERAL MONTHS LATER WHEN "THE
WASHINGTON POST" BROKE THE STORY
THAT HE, IN FACT, HAD TAKEN MANY
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS TAKEN TO
MAR-A-LAGO AND THAT WASN'T THE
LAST OF WHAT WAS RETRIEVED.
I DID FIND IT TO BE A REVEALING
MOMENT AND I WANTED PEOPLE TO
HEAR IT FOR THEMSELVES.
>> IT'S REALLY SOMETHING.
I ALSO WANT TO PLAY ANOTHER PART
OF ANOTHER INTERVIEW YOU DID
WITH HIM WHICH WAS ABOUT WHAT HE
WAS DOING ON JANUARY 6th AS THE
RIOT WAS HAPPENING.
HERE IT IS.
>> WHAT WERE YOU DOING WHEN --
HOW DID YOU FIND OUT THAT THERE
WERE PEOPLE STORMING THE
CAPITOL?
>> I HAD HEARD THAT AFTERWARDS
AND ACTUALLY ON THE LATE SIDE.
I WAS HAVING MEETINGS.
I WAS ALSO WITH MARK MEADOWS AND
OTHERS.
I WAS NOT WATCHING TELEVISION.
I DIDN'T HAVE THE TELEVISION ON.
>> YOU WEREN'T.
OKAY.
>> I DIDN'T USUALLY HAVE THE
TELEVISION ON.
I'D HAVE IT ON AND THERE WAS
SOMETHING.
I THEN LATER TURNED IT ON AND
SAW WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
I ALSO HAD CONFIDENCE THAT THE
CAPITOL, WHO DIDN'T WANT THESE
10,000 PEOPLE --
>> THE CAPITOL POLICE YOU MEAN.
>> -- THAT THEY'D BE ABLE TO
CONTROL THIS THING.
YOU DON'T REALIZE THAT THEY DID
LOSE CONTROL.
>> SO MUCH TESTIMONY SINCE THEN,
MAGGIE, THAT HE WAS WATCHING TV.
>> BREAIANNA WE REPORTED IN
REALTIME, CNN REPORTED IN
REALTIME THAT HE WAS WATCHING
TELEVISION.
WE WERE TOLD IT THAT DAY.
WE WERE TOLD IT IN THE DAYS
AFTER.
THE PUBLIC HEARING HELD BY THE
HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING THE JANUARY 6th
ATTACK HAS SINCE ESTABLISHED AND
DOCUMENTED THAT HE WAS WATCHING
TELEVISION.
AGAIN, IT WAS ANOTHER VERY
INTERESTING MOMENT BECAUSE MY
QUESTION WAS WHAT WERE
BRIANNA, WAS A HUGE MYSTERY,
EVEN WITH ALL OF OUR REPORTING.
THERE WAS NOTHING CERTAIN ABOUT
IT OR SAID UNDER OATH.
HIS IMPULSE WAS TO INSIST THAT
HE WASN'T DOING WHAT HE WAS
WIDELY REPORTED TO DO.
>> WHEN YOU SAID THAT TO HIM, HE
WASN'T WATCHING TV AND YOU SAID,
YOU WEREN'T, OKAY, DID YOU KNOW
AT THAT TIME HE WAS LYING TO
YOU?
>> I ASSUMED THAT THIS DID NOT
NECESSARILY COMPORT WITH
REALITY.
IT CERTAINLY DIDN'T COMPORT WITH
MY UNDERSTANDING OF IT.
AGAIN, BECAUSE WE DID NOT HAVE
HOUSE TESTIMONY, DIDN'T HAVE ANY
OF THE ITEMS WE NOW HAVE IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE BEING UNDER
OATH, IT WAS LESS CLEAR.
IT WAS STILL UNCLEAR EXACTLY
WHAT HE WAS CLAIMING, WHEN HE
LEARNED ABOUT IT OR HOW.
WE HAVE SINCE HEARD TESTIMONY
THAT HE WAS VERY CLEAR ON WHAT
WAS HAPPENING THROUGHOUT.
>> I'M ALSO CURIOUS WHAT HE TOLD
YOU AND WHAT YOU LEARNED ABOUT
HOW HE RELATED TO MITCH
McCONNELL WHICH I THINK IS
ESPECIALLY PERTINENT RIGHT NOW
IN LIGHT OF WHAT HE RECENTLY PUT
OUT ON SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT MITCH
McCONNELL SAYING HE HAS A DEATH
WISH WITH THIS RACIST INSULT OF
HIS WIFE, WHO IS FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FORMER
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY.
>> AMONG OTHER THINGS, DONALD
TRUMP HAS BEEN LEANING INTO
OVERT RACISM MORE THAN I THINK
WE HAVE SEEN HIM IN SOME TIME,
AND CERTAINLY MAKING THIS
STATEMENT ABOUT McCONNELL HAVING
A DEATH WISH, IT'S THE KIND OF
STATEMENT THAT DONALD TRUMP
MAKES AND THEN CLAIMS PEOPLE ARE
TAKING HIM OUT OF CONTEXT.
IT'S VERY HARD TO READ THAT IN
ANY OTHER WAY, ESPECIALLY IN THE
POST JANUARY 6th MOMENT AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE ARE SO
MANY LAWMAKERS FACING THREATS
AND THREATS OF VIOLENCE.
WHAT I MAKE OF IT IS TRUMP IS
LOOKING FOR A TARGET.
I THINK HE IS VERY ANGRY AT
McCONNELL FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
TRUMP HAS NEVER ACKNOWLEDGED
THAT MITCH McCONNELL PROTECTED
HIM AS PRESIDENT OVER AND OVER
AND SCHEPP HERDED HIS AGENDA
ITEMS THROUGH THE SFLAT.
HE'S MADE HIM A FOCUS OF HIS
EYRE, AND I EXPECT THAT WILL
CONTINUE, BRIANNA, AFTER WE
LEAVE THE MIDTERMS.
>> WHY IS THAT?
IS THAT BECAUSE HE WOULD PREFER
A FULL RHETORICAL EMBRACE?
>> I THINK ONE, HE WOULD PREFER
A FULL RHETORICAL EMBRACE.
ANOTHER IS THAT McCONNELL WAS
VERY, VERY CRITICAL OF DONALD
TRUMP'S ROLE OF THE JANUARY 6th
RIOTS AT THE CAPITOL.
HE GAVE A PRETTY BLISTERING
SPEECH, AND I THINK TRUMP
REACTED TO THAT AGGRESSIVELY.
THESE WERE NEVER PEOPLE,
BRIANNA, WHO HAD MUCH IN COMMON.
McCONNELL CLEARLY DIDN'T THINK
MUCH OF DONALD TRUMP BUT DID
ACCEPT THAT HE WAS THE LEADER OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND TRIED
TO GET WHAT POLICY INITIATIVES
HE BELIEVED IN THROUGH.
DONALD TRUMP I THINK KNEW THAT
MITCH McCONNELL DID NOT THINK
VERY HIGHLY OF HIM AND REACTED
TO THAT.
>> YOU ALSO HAVE INTERESTING
REPORTING IN THE BOOK ABOUT WHAT
IS, I GUESS, SORT OF CASUAL
RACISM AND HOMOPHOBIA AND
INSTANCES EVEN WHERE DONALD
TRUMP ASSUMES PEOPLE OF COLOR
ARE THERE FOR A CERTAIN ROLE AND
THEY ARE NOT.
>> NUMBER ONE, YES.
I THINK ONE OF THE
DRIVE-THROUGHLINES OF THE BOOK,
AND THIS BOOK, I WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR, IS A LOOK AT A LIFE, A
LOOK AT HOW WE GOT TO THIS
MOMENT IN THIS COUNTRY, HOW
DONALD TRUMP ENDED UP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND WHAT HE EXPORTED
FROM NEW YORK CITY TO NATIONAL
POLITICS WHICH CONTINUES TO THIS
DAY.
THAT'S THE POINT OF ALL THIS
REPORTING.
IT'S ALSO THE POINT OF THE
REPORTING ABOUT THE CASUAL
HOMOPHOBIA, THE CASUAL RACISM
WHICH WE GOT TO SEE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
IT ALSO EXISTED BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS AND ALSO EXISTED DECADES
EARLIER.
>> HOW DO YOU SEE HIM FITTING
INTO CAUSAL, SOMEONE WHO USES
PARTISANSHIP, HOW DO YOU SEE HIM
FITTING INTO PARTISANSHIP AS IT
IS TODAY?
>> SUCH A GOOD QUESTION.
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T CREATE THIS
PART SON MOMENT THAT WE'RE IN.
HE DIDN'T CREATE IT 11 YEARS
AGO, 1 YEARS AGO WHEN THE TEA
PARTY WAS AT ITS ZENITH IN THE
2010 MIDTERMS.
HE CERTAINLY TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
THAT MOMENT AND FUELED IT AND
BENEFITED FROM IT.
I WRITE THAT THE DONALD TRUMP
DAEKDS AGO CAME TO SEE HATE AS A
CIVIC GOOD.
IF THERE'S A DEFINING ETHOS HE
HAS, THAT IS IT.
HE'S HELPED RESHAPE POLITICS IN
SUCH TERMS THAT THEY ARE DEFINED
BY WHO YOU HATE AND WHO HATES
YOU BACK.
>> WE KNOW THAT DONALD TRUMP
EXPECTED THE DOJ TO BE SORT OF
AN INSTRUMENT OF HIS, EVEN, OF
COURSE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
INDEPENDENT.
IN YOUR BOOK YOU TALK ABOUT HIS
ATTEMPT TO GET THEM TO INTERVIEW
IN THE 2020 ELECTIONS.
YOU HAVE REPORTING ON TRUMP'S
ANGER WHEN HE LEARNED EARLIER
THAT THE DOJ WOULDN'T CHARGE
JAMES COMEY OVER THE HANDLING OF
MEMOS WITH CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION IN THEM.
YOU SAID TRUMP LEARNED THAT
BARR'S DEPARTMENT WAS NOT
CHARGING COMEY, INFURIATEDING
TRUMP.
HE MET THAT DAY WITH McDANIEL IN
THE DINING ROOM OFF THE OVAL
OFFICE FOR A PRESCHEDULED
MEETING DURING WHICH TRUMP
CALLED ONE PERSON AFTER ANOTHER,
WANTING TO KNOW IF THEY AGREED
WITH HIM THAT COMEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN CHARGED.
HE PAUSED AND THEN REACHED FOR A
REMOTE CONTROL, PICKED IT UP AND
THREW IT AT THE CREDENZA ALONG
THE WALL.
THIS IS A PRETTY REVEALING
MOMENT.
>> I POINT OUT THE REMOTE
CONTROL WAS THERE BECAUSE, IN
FACT, HE OFTEN WATCHED
TELEVISION IN THE WHITE HOUSE
DESPITE WHAT HE SAID.
YES, IT WAS A VERY JARRING
SCENE.
HE TAKES THE REMOTE, THROWS IT
AGAINST THE WALL.
HE HAS A PENSION FOR THROWING
THINGS
WE HEARD TESTIMONY FROM CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON, I HAVE HAD OTHER
SOURCES TELL ME WAS TRUE, AT AN
INCIDENT WHERE HE THREW FOOD.
I HAVE A SCENE IN THE BOOK FROM
DECADES AGO WHERE AN EMPLOYEE
QUIT AND HE THREW SOMETHING AT
THE EMPLOYEE WHEN THE EMPLOYEE
QUIT THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
ONE FRIEND RECALLED IT BEING A
SHOE.
THIS IS A PATTERN WITH HIM.
THIS IS SOMETHING WITH HIM THAT
COMES UP OVER AND OVER.
>> SO LOOKING TO 2024, WHAT DO
YOU SEE?
>> AT THE MOMENT I'M SEEING
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BACKED HIMSELF
INTO A CORNER AND I THINK HAS TO
RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
NOW, WHETHER HE DOES AND WHETHER
HE ANNOUNCES AND STAYS IN OR
WHETHER HE JUST CONTINUES
RUNNING AND BECOMES A NOMINEE
AGAIN IS OBVIOUSLY AN OPEN
QUESTION.
HE IS CLEARLY A FORMIDABLE
PRESENCE WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
I THINK PEOPLE UNDERESTIMATE
THAT AT THEIR OWN PERIL.
HE HAS A WAY OF COMING BACK WHEN
PEOPLE THINK THAT HE IS DONE.
THAT IS ALSO ONE OF THE
NARRATIVE ARCS THROUGH THIS
BOOK.
RIGHT NOW HE DOES NOT SEEM BY
ALL KNTS, OF EVERYONE I'VE
TALKED TO, HIS HEART DOESN'T
SEEM INTO POLITICS THE WAY IT
ONCE WAS.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE THAT SORT OF
FIRE IN HIS BELLY.
DOES HE HAVE THE ENERGY, THE
STAMINA?
>> WE'VE SEEN THE RALLIES.
HE CERTAINLY HAS THE STAMINA TO
GO THROUGH THE RALLIES.
WHAT ISN'T CLEAR IS THAT HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE DESIRE ANYMORE.
WHEN YOU HAVE BEEN A PRESIDENT
AND YOU'RE GOING BACK TO DOING
RALLIES, THAT IS NOT THE ONLY
THING HE LOOKED ABOUT BEING
PRESIDENT.
WHEN YOU ARE REDUCED TO PLAYING
RALLIES OVER AND OVER AGAIN, I
THINK THAT GETS IN YOU